oh my monster you were almost good the
Crimson horror we continue to move our
way through overdue Doctor Who as I
revisit previous episodes and we've
arrived at the Crimson horror which is
set in Victorian London which means
Jenny Strax ambassador are back it's
funny going back and doing this revisit
at this particular point has served to
remind me something that I think I'd
forgotten that for as much as I like
Jenny Strax ambassador as characters and
as a trio they're not in very many good
stories this one it's actually very
funny to me I don't know if anyone else
has my sense of humor in terms of I have
been able to pinpoint so precisely what
went wrong with this episode and I will
do that but stick around so when I say
this episode doesn't work and falls
apart etc I stand by that except it's
not really bad and actually falls apart
is the wrong term it just doesn't land
the way it's supposed to and a lot of
the things that's trying for aren't
working as well as they should be again
I have identified the one single change
they could have made that would make I'm
pretty sure all this work better if not
just great but let's look at what we've
got here we have an interesting starting
premise in that we begin with only Jenny
Strax and vastra beginning to
investigate this whole thing of the
Crimson horror the doctor isn't there
initially we get teased him because in
the dead man's eye and I do like that
they establish that that doesn't
actually work and it's just weird
chemical composite go around the body
that makes it work this time like it's a
toss off line and prob
necessary but I kind of like that they
don't validate this very debunked thing
so that works for me so they're on the
case as it were and Jenny gets to
infiltrate I like that we get more time
with Jenny I like and I like that we get
more time with her actually away from
vastra so that she's not just part of a
double act she gets to feel a little bit
more like her own character and we get a
little bit more of that feistiness not
just in contracts too vast reserved Airy
cool calculated way of being but just in
vacuum by herself and she's a lot of fun
I actually think I like Jenny the best
out of the three if I'm being completely
honest though that might have a little
bit to do with her armor combat outfit
hmm and strikes strikes really is but I
think he has some of his better jokes in
this one because your here's where a
Strax joke fails as opposed to works a
Strax joke fails I think when it hinges
on the idea that he's stupid or did
something stupid that's why I say for
instance the memory worm joke in snowmen
while not painful didn't really work
that well because it just hinged on him
being stupid because he kept handling
the thing without the gauntlet
what I like about the humors here is
that they hinge on how the way he
approaches and thinks about things is
different from basically everybody else
in the room so Jenny's getting ready to
infiltrate this place and he just gives
this list of these weapons and like you
should have all these things and why
just in general like that that's a solid
strikes joke because it hinges on what
makes him unique which is Sontaran
coming at things with a Sontaran mindset
whereas whenever they hinge on the idea
that he's just stupid those jokes annoy
me and some of the better jokes with
Strax are in here so that's nice that
works for me as well of course look
we've got Diana Rigg on hand and while
the full payoff involving her between
the bat character gillyflower
I'm just gonna call a diner because
that's even when I talked about her
being in Game of Thrones I usually just
referred to her as Diana Rigg rather
than Lady Elaine entero cuz it's Diana
Rigg anyways
you know she's there and her her
daughter ADA actually the actress is her
own daughter so in real life so that's
cool and there should be a stronger
emotional payoff to that whole thing
between the two of them between her and
her daughter and you can see where it
should work but it doesn't quite land as
well as it should the daughter in
general I my memory was that the
performance wasn't great it's actually
quite good but it's again it's not quite
paying off right not that they're paying
off by having it do the wrong things
it's not a writing issue of they're
paying things off in the wrong way it's
that for some reason when they get to
the pay off of things like her finding
out that what her mother has done to her
her turning on her mother her mother's
you know losing the the mr. sweet the
alien which I'll come back to like that
works but it should work better than it
does and again there is one single
reason and I'm almost there we'll get to
it soon I'm mr. sweet I do want to touch
on that was kind of a cool thing in and
of itself just the this alien parasite
that works the way it did and also it
works well with that relationship
because this woman has neglected her
actual daughter for this parasite in
this parasite which is attached here
it's on the upper chest but it's
effectively suckling at her and she's
ignoring her actual blood child for the
sake of this parasite yeah that works
that that I sometimes go off about
themes or where themes should be
matching or they don't or a good thumb
at ik that's good theming that is a that
makes the parasite representative of the
Rif to put
these two characters that's good theming
but again despite those themes being
there they don't pay off as well and
they don't pay off for one very simple
mistake that the episode made the
doctors brought into the story too early
the doctor should have been absent until
I'm gonna say the last 10 minutes
possibly even closer to the tail end
because we needed more time with Ada and
especially with ADA's relationship with
this monster that she's keeping we get
like one little scene and then like he's
escaped and we see how that affects her
but that doesn't land the way it should
either because we didn't get to see like
how much she clings to this that should
have been a much bigger basically all
the time that was the doctor stumbling
around trying to get to move again with
Jenny all of that and honestly as much
as I'd like Jenny's fighting outfit the
initial action scenes before the
unveiling of mr. sweet all of that chuck
it in the bin give us more time with Ada
and the doctor before we know that it's
the doctor and Ada and her mother so
that that relationship in that
connection the connection that she makes
with what to her as a monster and the
distance between her and her mother
means that everything actually lands
with the full force that it should be
landing with on paper but isn't because
once the doctor is on the scene he sucks
the oxygen out of the room and he just
takes any he takes literal time and also
energy away from these supporting
characters who are played by very good
actresses and who really could have had
that hit really hard but they aren't
given enough time no matter how good an
actor you are if the writing and the
script and the editing does not give you
the time needed to properly convey
something or for the audience to bond
with you as a character the way that you
need to then it won't work and
is the core of this thing seriously that
one change just delay the doctor getting
there and used the time that you've
gained to spend more time with a to
spend more time with her mother spend
more time on appreciating especially
with Ada what she's going through and
what's going on so that when she turns
on her mother beats her with a cane and
says to her face when her mother says
would please forgive me as she says
never which first of all as someone who
cannot freaking stand the idiots Lantern
which espouses the well you have to
forgive him he's your dad thank you
although it's mildly undercut by your
mother going that's my girl implying
that her not forgiving her mother is
somehow an evil thing since an evil
person is a program of what she did but
I'll take it
and her then crushing the parasite all
of that would hit the way it should the
way that these actresses deliver it it
would hit as hard as they are trying to
get it if they just didn't feel the need
to bring the doctor in as early as they
freaking do it's a bummer because it is
really close and thus toughness there is
still good the performances for for
Diana Rigg and from you know ADA they
they're still good Dinaric especially
brings a lot she didn't need that much
more screen time because she has enough
raw presence that it works for a villain
we really needed more time with Ada and
this could have been great as it stands
it's just kind of okay Crimson horror
Yuri watched it lately what you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
thank you so much for tuning in you can
do all the usual stuff like subscribe
share this around hit the bell if you
want to get notifications every time
there's a new video there's a new one
four times a week also feel free to
check out my other channel break room of
geeks and of course I have a patreon
which they'll be linked for at the end
of this video and also down in the
description I am supported by the
wonderful names you are now seeing
scrolling in front of your face they
help me keep this thing going you could
as well but no pressure I won't tell you
what to do because you're the council
I'm just not in the meetings
[Music]